can i ask you about
substances chemical substances that
affect the video game
the dream world
so psychedelics
that increasingly have been getting a
lot of research done on them so in
general psychedelics uh psilocybin mdma
but also really interesting one the big
one which is dmt
what and where are the places that these
substances take
the mind that is operating in the dream
world
do you have an interesting sense how
this
throws a wrinkle
into the prediction model
is it just some weird little quirk or is
there
is there some fundamental expansion of
the mind going on
i suspect that a way to look at
psychedelics is that they induce
particular types of lucid dreaming
states so it's a state in which certain
connections are being
severed in your mind when no longer
active your mind basically gets free to
move in a certain direction because some
inhibition some particular inhibition
doesn't work anymore
and as a result you might stop having
yourself or you might
stop perceiving the world as
three-dimensional
and
you can explore that state
and i suppose that for every state that
can be induced with psychedelics there
are people that are naturally in that
state
so uh sometimes psychedelics that shift
you through a range of possible mental
states and they can also shift you out
of the range of permissible mental
states that is where you can make
predictive models of reality
and what i observe in people that use
psychedelics
a lot is that they tend to be
overfitting
overfitting means that you are
using more bits for modeling the
dynamics of a function then you should
and so you can fit your curve to
extremely detailed things in the past
but this model is no longer predictive
for the future
what is it about psychedelics that
forces that
i thought it would be the opposite i
thought
uh that it's a good mechanism
for uh
for generalization for regularization so
it feels like
psychedelics expansion of the mind like
taking you outside of like forcing your
model to be
uh non-predictive is a good thing
meaning like uh it's almost like okay
what i would uh say psychedelics are
akin to is traveling to a totally
different environment
like going if you've never been to like
india or something like that from the
united states very different set of
people different culture different food
different
roads and
values and all those kinds of things
yeah so psychedelics can for instance
teleport people into
a universe that is hyperbolic which
means that if you imagine a room that
you're in you can turn around 360
degrees and you didn't go full circle
you need to go 720 degrees to go full
circle exactly so uh the things that
people learn in that state cannot be
easily transferred in this universe that
we are in
it could be that if they're able to
abstract and understand what happened to
them that they understand that some part
of their spatial cognition
has been desynchronized and has found a
different synchronization and this
different synchronization happens to be
a hyperbolic one right so you learn
something interesting about your brain
it's difficult to understand what
exactly happened but we get a pretty
good idea once we understand how the
brain is representing geometry yeah but
doesn't give you a fresh perspective on
the physical reality
who's making that sound
is inside my head or is it external
well there is no sound outside of your
mind but uh it's making sense
of phenomena in physics
uh yeah in the physical reality there's
uh there's sound waves
traveling through air okay
that's our model of what happened
tomorrow what happened right
uh
doesn't uh don't psychedelics give you a
fresh perspectives on this physical
reality
like uh
not this physical reality but this this
more um
[Applause]
what do you call the dream world that's
mapped directly to purpose of dreaming
at night i think is yeah theater
augmentation well
exactly so that's where you're very
different that's very similar just
change parameters uh about the things
that you have learned
and for instance when you are young you
have seen things from certain
perspectives but not from others so your
brain is generating new perspectives of
objects that you already know which
means they can learn to recognize them
later from different perspectives and i
suspect that's the reason why many of us
remember to have flying dreams as
children because it's just different
perspectives of the world that we
already know and that it it starts to
generate these
different perspective changes and then
it fluidly turns this into a flying
dream to make sense of what's happening
right so you fill in the gaps and
suddenly you see yourself flying
and
similar things can happen with semantic
relationships so it's not just spatial
relationships but it can also be the id
relationships between ideas that are
being changed
and it seems that the mechanisms that
make that happen during dreaming
are interacting with these same
receptors
that are being stimulated by
psychedelics
so
i suspect that there is a thing that i
haven't read really about the way in
which dreams are induced in the brain is
not just that the
activity of the brain gets tuned down
because you are somehow your eyes are
closed and you no longer get enough data
from your eyes but there is a particular
type of neurotransmitter that is
saturating your brain during these
phases during the rm phases and you
produce
controlled hallucinations
and psychedelics are linking into these
mechanisms
i suspect so isn't it an another
trickier form of data augmentation yes
but it's also data augmentation that can
happen outside of the specification that
your brain is tuned to so basically
people are overclocking their brains and
that
that produces states that are
subjectively extremely interesting
yeah i just but from the outset very
suspicious
i i think i'm over applying the metaphor
of a neural network in my own mind uh
which
i just think that doesn't lead to
overfitting right but
but you were just sort of anecdotally
saying my experiences with people that
have no psychedelics or that that kind
of quality i think it typically happens
so if you look at people like timothy
leary and he has written beautiful
manifestos about
the effect of lsd on people he genuinely
believed he writes in these manifestos
that in the future science and art will
only be done on psychedelics because
it's so much more efficient and so much
better and he gave
lsd to children in this community of a
few thousand people that he had near san
francisco and
basically he was losing touch
with reality he did not understand the
effects that the things that he was
doing would have on the reception of
psychedelics by society because he was
unable to think critically about what
happened what happened was that he got
in an euphoric state that euphoric state
happened because he was overfitting he
was taking this sense of euphoria and
translating it into a model of actual
success in the world right he was
feeling better
limitations had disappeared that he exp
appearance to be existing that he didn't
get superpowers i understand what you
mean by overfitting now
there's a lot of interpretation to the
term overfitting in this case but i i
got you so he was getting
he was getting uh positive rewards from
a lot of actions this year but not just
this so if you take for instance john
lilly who um was studying dolphin
languages and uh aliens and so on yeah a
lot of people that use psychedelics
became very loopy
and the typical thing that you notice
when people are in psychedelics is that
they are in a state where they feel that
everything can be explained now
everything is clear everything is
obvious yeah and
sometimes they have indeed discovered a
useful connection but not always very
often these connections are over
interpretations
i wonder
you know there's a question of
correlation versus causation
and also i wonder if it's the
psychedelics or if it's more the social
like being the outsider
uh and having a strong community of
outside and being having a leadership
position in an outside occult-like
community that could have a much
stronger effect of overfitting than do
psychedelics themselves the actual
substances
because it's a counterculture thing so
it could be that as opposed to the
actual substance if you're a boring
person who wears a suit and tie and
works at a bank
uh and takes psychedelics that could be
a very different effect of psychedelics
on
on your mind i'm just sort of raising
the point that the people you referenced
are already weirdos i'm not sure exactly
oh no not necessarily a lot of the
people that
tell me that they use psychedelics in a
useful way
started out as squares and were
liberating themselves because they were
stuck
they were basically stuck in local
optimum of their own self model of their
relationship to the world and suddenly
they had data augmentation they
basically saw
an experience the space of possibilities
they experienced what it would be like
to be another person yeah and they took
uh
important lessons from that experience
back home
yeah i mean uh i love the the the
metaphor of data augmentation because
that's
been the the primary driver of
self-supervised learning in the vision
computer vision domain is data
augmentation so it's funny to think of
data augment like
like chemically induced
data augmentation in the human mind
there's also a very interesting effect
that i uh
noticed i've i know uh several people
who uh sphere to me that
lsd has cured their migraines
so severe cluster headaches or migraines
that didn't respond to standard
medication that disappeared after a
single dose and i don't recommend
anybody doing this especially not in the
us where it's illegal
and there are no studies on this for
that reason but it seems that
anecdotally that it basically
can reset the serotonergic system so
it's basically
pushing them outside of their normal
boundaries and as a result it needs to
find a new equilibrium and in some
people that equilibrium is better but it
also follows that in other people it
might be worse so if you have a brain
that is already teetering on the
boundary to psychosis
it can be permanently pushed over that
boundary well that's why you have to do
good science which they're starting to
do on all these different substances of
how well actually works for the
different conditions like mdma seems to
help with ptsd
uh same with psilocybin
that you know you need to do good
science meaning large studies of large
and yeah so based on the existing
studies with mdma it seems that um
if you look at rick doblin's work and
what he has published about this and
talks about uh mdma seems to be a
psychologically relatively safe drug but
it's physiologically not very safe that
is uh there is a neurotoxicity if you
would use two large dose and if you
combine this with alcohol which a lot of
kids do in uh party settings during
raves and so on it's very hip
hepatotoxic so basically you can kill
your liver
and this means that it's probably
something that is best and most
productively used in clinical setting by
people who really know what they're
doing and i suspect that's also true for
the other psychedelics that is uh while
the other second eggs are probably not
as toxic as say alcohol uh the effects
on nisaki can be much more profound and
lasting
yeah well as far as i know psilocybin so
mushrooms magic mushrooms
uh as far as i know in terms of the
studies they're running i think have no
over like they're allowed to do what
they're calling heroic doses so that one
does not have a toxicity so they could
do like huge doses in a clinical setting
when they're doing study on psilocybin
which is kind of fun
yeah it seems that most of the
psychedelics work in extremely small
doses
which means that the effect on the rest
of the body is relatively low and mdma
is probably the exception maybe ketamine
can be dangerous and larger doses
because it can
depress breathing and so on but
the
lsd and psilocybin work in very very
small doses at least the active part of
them
of um lsd is only the active part
and
the but the effect that you it can have
on your mental wiring can be very
dangerous i think
you